I had an amazing evening last night I
came out and we got together with family
that I had never met and in fact I found
out from my late father's he had written
his memoirs and I just got a chance to
read those recently that in fact his
father's brother had a big house in Palo
Alto and so I found out that the family
some of whom were here many of them are
Stanford graduates or current Stanford
students that was interesting what was
really good was I found out they owned
the house and I also have reason to
believe they owned all the land that
Stanford is on and still do we're
flexible we work out some kind of rental
agreement I think but they'll have to be
a few changes and I think you'll get
used to uniforms in marchin over time
we're going to talk about a couple of
things today and I thought that one of
the things that a good thing to talk
about is the meaning of life and the
meaning of life of course is explained
in this diagram here if I put this up if
they taught it at West Point the cadets
would be required to measure the length
work the angles know exactly what the
balls are but they wouldn't give a damn
whether they knew the meaning of life
but I was counseled here that I'm
speaking to a very August crowd and so I
should not speak down to Stanford
students so any questions
this is going to be a lot easier than I
thought from 30th September 2004 in the
LML neighbourhood of Baghdad in Iraq
five seasoned hard looking men moved
down the street very difficult time in
that part of the city they moved into an
abandoned house and inside there was
still some furniture broken glass and
things like that and they met three
other men they began to discuss an
operation they were soldiers they began
to discuss an operation that would be
conducted this was a difficult part of
the war those individuals knew war they
made plans to conduct an operation would
be both dangerous for them and require
very very careful planning ultimately
because of the nature of the operation
they wore local garb and they used local
vehicles and they had two vehicles and
then they had some people who would move
on foot when they were prepared they
occupied two of the vehicles and then
the people on foot took off and they
moved toward their target where their
enemy was meeting the enemy was meeting
at the opening of a water sewage plant
as the individuals came the first
vehicle carried the first group of
Fighters to moved to the target area it
moved right into the crowd and then with
a click of a switch the car exploded it
created mayhem but the crowd began to
gather back in again the crowd had been
Iraqi officials American soldiers
handing out candy to young children and
a disproportionate young number of Iraqi
children when the crowd had filled back
in again the second car
arrived and it too detonated 42 human
beings were killed 35 of whom were
children 141 people were wounded 72 of
which were also children and the sense
of a military operation of the kind that
we are not normally prepared for had to
be gathered because this group of
Fighters were al-qaida in Iraq
they've become hardened professionals in
a sense and they conduct a very well run
operation with a new set of rules so
today I thought we talked about doing
the right thing I'm not going to talk
about it from a sense of morality
I'm going to talk about a sense of what
this means for the future of
organizational leadership how things are
happening in the real world and how I
think that they will happen in the
future
in 2003 I took command of the Joint
Special Operations Command that
organization was known by its acronym
JSOC I'd served in it for much of my
career I'd serve in Afghanistan before
this and I took command of its of this
unique organization and this
organization was formed after the
failure of the 1980 attempt to rescue
Americans held hostage in the American
Embassy in Tehran and it was designed to
bring together America's most elite
special operating units Delta Force
seals Rangers others into this umbrella
organization or Task Force that could do
all the difficult missions that the
nation envisioned we would need in the
future
the failure of the Iranian rescue
mission Operation Eagle Claw gave
impetus and fairly quickly the
resourcing and talent gave real strength
of this command real ability so when I
took command in the fall of 2003 in Iraq
by 2004
if I were to describe JSOC to you it was
a pretty unique entity it was elite
every individual in the organization
went through a selection and assessment
process selection to get it to get
selected then a very detailed training
process it was well resourced
extraordinarily so better than any other
part of the US military in fact if you
had an idea of a new piece of equipment
or a requirement or weapon we had the
ability to fund and get that on very
very rapid timelines and it was
efficient he had developed processes it
had developed a culture of doing things
very very well so it was this very
effective unique entity by the summer of
2004 we were also losing and you say
what is losing mean it's not like not
making a profit this quarter it doesn't
feel like that it feels and looks much
different than that it feels like
tragedy it feels like loss of life it
feels like loss of national and
individual futures and dreams and it
procore acquires people to come to grips
with the fact you can lose and you have
to do something about it we knew that
something was different in this
particular fight we were so good but we
knew that the environment was different
the 21st century was different than what
we had prepared for and what we had
experienced earlier in our careers and
needed something new but we didn't know
what it was we just knew we were doing
all the other things we'd been taught to
do but they weren't working like they
used to work so today what I do is I
thought I'd take you through what we
think had changed what we needed to do
and then ultimately what we did so let's
talk about change everybody goes through
change in your professional life in your
personal life when I was young I hit
things pretty good
as you can see I saved money on what
beer I drank to buy nice trousers but my
misspent youth had a in date and that
end date came this day when any corcoran
then agreed to be my wife and imagine me
looking down the aisle see a beautiful
girl and then seeing her dad rut row but
when you get married a lot of things
change in your life but one thing
doesn't change at all Annie hasn't
changed in 37 years not at all I have to
say that that's how you make 37 years
but your life changes and pretty soon
after that a few years later Annie
blessed us with a child a son and so I
did what everybody does when you got a
son I hang them upside down I flipped
him around like this and then he does
what every mother does she goes don't do
that you give him brain damage I said
I'm not gonna give him brain damage this
is my son in high school maybe a little
bit but he waltz through Florida State
for a four-year degree in seven years
but just are you think there isn't
justice in the world he's in Afghanistan
now serving for the government so it
does come around but things change
things change a lot for each of us and
change in the environment we got to
recognize admit it and deal with it so
what's the new environment look like
well we throw all kinds of words about
the new environment all the buzzwords I
don't even know what recursive means but
I it means change I guess but when I
look at all of this really two terms
came down after we studied this that
really meant more than all the others
one was tight coupling and what we mean
by tight coupling is when things are
linked together or networked almost like
a power grid or an ecosystem or a set of
computers that are linked together when
they're coupled so that when something
happens in one part of it it may affect
all or parts of the rest of it and you
think of this in an ecosystem of fish
and whatnot and if something happens in
one maybe food source or whatever
suddenly you can have this cascading
effect that you're really not ready for
and it's very very complex and tight
coupling increases it and then tight
coupling is affected by speed and we say
okay we know things are faster but we
don't really know how much faster it is
think about how things used to arrive to
you maybe the oldest people here today
remember this kind of delivery but
probably most of us will see this kind
of delivery things will happen at a
speed we're not prepared and when you
put the two things together the effects
of tight coupling and speed you get some
interesting effects but what do you
effected you're affecting what we called
the elegant solution this is what was
taught in business schools for many many
years yell against solution was great I
mean just look at it it looks good put
that on the wall here off this looks
like you know what's going on
information goes down goes through set
paths after a certain period of time at
the end of the day into the weekend of
the month whatever you specify the
information comes back up there are
right angles there are blocks that fit
neatly in different parts of the
organization if they need to communicate
there's a process to do that it's going
to go this way you're going to talk to
this and it's going to happen just like
this you know it was designed the
elegant solution was designed to create
order to solve a problem to create
efficiency and people are always doing
that at the end of the first world war
the great takeaway was that defensive
arms were stronger than offensive arms
and trenches worked very well to stop
enemy attacks so in the interwar years
specifically the 1930s the French looked
at a growing strength in Nazi Germany
and they decided we need to do something
to protect ourselves so they created
something which has become almost a
byword for stupidity they created
something called the Maginot Line and
the Maginot Line was designed to defend
the border between France and Germany
from German invasion and if you look at
the Maginot Line it was actually pretty
amazing thing at the top it had these
steel cupola and partially buried cement
and concrete facilities very difficult
to target very difficult to get at but
easy to man with a small number of
forces vertically it went down on the
ground and it had elevators that went
down through multiple levels and at the
multiple levels like at one level you
have ammunition another level you'll
actually have railroads that connect the
different parts of the line for very
efficient the idea was with a very small
number of forces you could defend
against a huge potential German attack
and together it was a pretty amazing
engineering feat everybody says well
this is just a monument I think Patton
said a monument to the stupidity of man
the thing about the Maginot Line is it
worked it did exactly what it was
designed to do the Germans did not
breach the Maginot Line in 1940 when
they bet when they
invaded France the French had solved
that problem but they had not solved the
real problem the big problem the Germans
went around it they went to the north
and they came through so in effect the
solution worked but didn't solve the
problem so the answer was to an
incorrect question shall we go back to
the elegant solution and we start to say
well it's so neat it's so clean it's so
comfortable what could be bad about this
or what could be the weakness because it
was vertically stratified into
horizontal tears tears of rank or
authority
it was horizontally stratified into
vertical silos typically around a
functional area part of an organization
and if you think of the horizontal
tearing information would go down and it
would go up but it assumed that the
organization had adequate time for
information that flow through those
pathways but speed as things sped up
actions around them suddenly that was
tested that has been tested and with
within the vertical silos the functional
silos there was an assumption that as
you broke these silos down you assumed
an exclusive relationship ie the vast
majority of the interaction is inside
those silos
and it fits comfortably there and if
somebody needs to do business most of
what they do can be done right inside
that silo but as tight coupling kicks in
and increases in its reality suddenly if
you've got to do business in one part of
the organization but it doesn't reside
only in your silo if it affects many
other parts of the organization suddenly
you got problems because across the
organization the pathways to connect
these parts and deal with the tight
coupling are ponderous
so speed and tight coupling suddenly
challenged the functionality of the
elegant solution so what did we need
that was really what we faced what did
we need in Iraq first off as I talked
about JSOC was tasked with defeating al
Qaeda in Iraq which we called a Qi and
go back and look at what was the force I
had it was an extraordinary two elite
effective force conventionally organized
it had some really important traits had
very clear and effective structure
it had very understood and rehearsed
processes it could measure what it did
and it could optimize or get the most
efficiency out of the organization
possible hit the most number of targets
do it with the right kinds of people and
so efficiency the most effective
executors should have been dominant and
in fact we didn't know it at the time we
were actually disciples of a guy named
Frederick Winslow Taylor born in the
middle of the 19th century near
Philadelphia son of a very successful
lawyer Frederick Winslow Taylor in 1874
applied to college there was no Stanford
so he applied to Harvard he got accepted
to Harvard but he wisely chose instead
to go work on a factory floor just take
a basic job on a factory floor and there
he became fanatical in his desire to
understand the concept of best practices
what works best how do you get the most
efficiency out of an organization and he
eventually produced a book which are
undoubtedly familiar with scientific
management and became a Bible really for
the 20th century and how we do things
break everything into its tasks
something we could call reductionism and
then pull those tasks together and if
they're all efficiency done efficiently
done you got a great process
I think it's really
represented well by a really good
assembly line if you get that right it's
going to be hard for any other approach
to be more effective against this we
have al-qaeda in Iraq they were not
organized like we were they were
organized like this loose network of
associations we kept trying to put them
on whiteboards and we map out their
structure top and tiers down but they
never got that memo and they were
instead organized by friendships and
family associations in who'd served
together in Afghanistan who had other
relationship who was married to whose
sister I don't think this was carefully
thought out and planned but it became
the organic way in which they were
structured and what it gave them was
extraordinary adaptability because they
didn't have a manual that they were
violating their manual was survive and
win and so suddenly this extraordinary
the apogee of efficiency is up against
this child of adaptability and we were
having big problems so we felt a lot
about this and you say what is
efficiency efficiency if you get it down
here it's getting the most why what you
want with the least X it's making the
most cars with the least steel it's
doing the most raids with the fewest
forces it's making the most money with
the least investment and it's pretty
straightforward all you got to do is
clarify what Y is and then focus until
you figure out the most efficient X but
it assumes you know y it assumes you
know what you have to do the the output
or requirement but speed and tight
coupling and produce something we call
emergent properties and emergent
properties are when you put together
phenomenon like those you get unexpected
outcomes you get a different environment
that those qualities have changed
and so suddenly why is not so easy to
solve for think of it this way we're
going to talk about Springs as we get
more data now we can collect more
information now very very quickly and we
can predict whether or better than ever
before
now forget things like global warming
but just typical weather patterns as we
get more and more information our
ability to predict weather has gotten
increasingly effective so it ought to
apply to everything but think of the
Arab Spring we have more and more
ability to watch what happening talk to
people deal more and more data but in
reality the Arab Spring is a complex
event that is affected itself by more
data as more information passes more
communication more complexity so we are
trying to gather more data but
exponentially that which we are trying
to measure and predict is more complex
so more data does not equal more
predictability and that can produce
something we call predictive hubris in
1973 they did a study and the study gave
people who were well experienced in
horse racing information first they gave
them ten pieces of information about all
the horses and they asked them to
predict the outcome and they measured
their confidence in how accurate they
thought their prediction would be then
they gave them 20 variables and asked
the same thing interestingly enough with
10 variables their accuracy was X with
20 variables with 20 pieces of
information their accuracy didn't go up
at all but their confidence that they
had it right went up significantly so
they were more confident probably with
the second than they should have been
because they had more data but they
didn't really have more reason to be
accurate so you can have a phenomenon
which predictive hubris and think of the
times in life where we assume
something is going to happen because it
has happened before because data says it
is and then we are completely surprised
so now we say if we're going to go back
to our equation of getting the most with
the least well X what if you don't know
why and it's pretty hard to figure out
the other variables
suddenly you're dealing with constantly
changing requirement you don't even know
what the problem you're going to have to
solve tomorrow is so getting a perfectly
efficient solution to that is elusive
so adaptability becomes the holy grail
and the way I put that is adaptability
is a difference between doing things
right doing things by established
processes habits training and doing the
right thing doing what works becomes
your attention and if you go back to
Iraq the difference between my force and
al-qaeda in Iraq as much as we tried we
carried the baggage of doing things
right if you don't violate your
processes the principles you've been
taught people won't criticize you even
if you fail but I did all the right
things now if you lost you obviously
didn't against an enemy whose only
metric was survival and success so
efficiency comes up against adaptability
an efficiency comes up the loser so what
we did was we melded the two we tried to
take the best of what we do put it
together with extreme adaptability and
change the way we thought and operated
to make it work so how did we do that
what did it look and feel like we all
know small teams everybody's been on a
basketball team or small class or
something where it just feels easy you
can finish each other's sentences you
can predict what people are going to do
what's the nature of those that allows
that to happen most of us remember the
first of May 2011 and the raid that
ultimately killed Osama bin Laden
had we been watching in real time as
some people were in the White House and
other locations as the two special
helicopters came to land in the compound
one of the helicopters crash-landed now
that's 50% of your assault force crash
lands before you get anywhere
eyeball-to-eyeball with the enemy and
you go we're screwed
but if you understand these operations
and while I was in command we probably
did several thousand of equal complexity
something always went wrong that was
well within the span of what we
typically expected an experience so when
an aircraft goes down it's not like I we
got to go back and try again another day
nope we deal with it and so that had
been built into the DNA of the force
that had been built into the people so
what does make a team great we always
say well go get the best people you can
some of its parts
get together talent and you're going to
win I call out the dream team fallacy
for those of you remember the American
the u.s. men's basketball team in 2004
brought together the best professional
basketball players in the world walked
away with a bronze medal while Argentina
got the gold so strictly speaking just
talent doesn't do it a team is not the
sum of its parts there's something else
Navy SEALs this calendar came out in
1992 we gave him amazing amount of [ __ ]
over this
as you can imagine but if you think of
Navy SEALs you say why are seals so
effective it's because they are all
genetically superior brilliant motivated
etc but in reality to be a seal it's
difficult but there are many people who
can do it
thus the physical standard for swimming
is to do two miles in 75 minutes with
fins now not everybody here can do two
miles in 75 minutes but this 64 year-old
Lady Diana Nyad did two miles in less
than 75 minutes and then she swam a
hundred and eight more miles staying
under that same pace the whole time so
it's not a case of Superman it's not a
case of people who just are identified
for their exquisite abilities it's
something else and I think part of that
is trust and purpose now what is trust
trust is we use the term a lot but I'm
not sure we really know what it is it's
faith in your colleagues but it's also
familiarity with them it's that special
relationship that comes between people
in organizations where you absolutely
know and can rely on what they're going
to do and why and it builds that special
bond in Navy SEAL training called basic
underwater demolition school buds
everything is designed to build trust
between people they have to go somewhere
with another swim buddy all the time all
of the drills that are done are done
with either a group or at least one
other person it's designed to build that
special linkage of trust and purpose one
of the things that we do in elite units
is we make the training regimen to get
in the selection process so hellacious
that it takes this huge commitment it
involves physical pain sometimes fear
often a lot of sacrifice of time
other things to get in that organization
and to be a part of that you have made a
big commitment to be a part of that one
of the things it does is it helps
identify those people who are aligned
and it also increases the alignment
because that's what you invested in you
tend to feel committed to and so really
trust and purpose changes the basic
calculus between individuals
so trust in purpose is an emotional
linkage then you give them a contextual
linkage ie they have shared information
they all can get access to shared
information suddenly you get something
that we call shared consciousness now
that shared consciousness is almost a
magical property because people who have
trust and purpose and then they
understand and see similarly not agree
with everything that's not the point but
it produces this emergent intelligence
and awareness that is shared between
them so think about it ants
the average ant is said to have seven
neurons of brain power I served with
guys with about that level but hundreds
of thousands of ants can come together
and without a spoken language without a
written language without any handbook
without any formal education they can
create these extraordinarily fun
functional colonies and do these amazing
things like this anthill seven neurons
of brains so now let me
for just a second here because I've got
a classmate of mine from West Point here
a guy named ed Evans and he and I were
right at the bottom of the class in math
and I just want to celebrate the moment
with you ed that I am a Stanford's
business school teaching a math equation
our instructors would roll over in their
graves so what am I saying here I'm
saying efficiency or effectiveness of
the team the excellence is a function of
the individual excellence the talent the
commitment of individuals and a and
shared consciousness sort of makes sense
and that individual excellence is what
we bring to the table or or was built
inside us and then that connection
between us is that almost that magic
elixir the changes that relationship and
you can apply this at various levels
excellence at different levels you can
look at it that way we're familiar with
small teams because that's sort of
natural but think of it at any given
level it's a function of excellence one
level down the component pieces times
the level of shared consciousness one
level down so if your pieces work
together and we would think about it
this way a SEAL team an aggregate unit
of seals is the function of individual
seals times that shared consciousness
shared between them now in JSOC we we
understood this intuitively it was in
our culture it was in our DNA it was how
we operated it was how we thought it was
everything about who we were but yet at
the next level we got it completely
wrong because at the JSOC level where we
were a larger unit that was made up of
larger components
suddenly at the team level we had really
good teams but when we did things to
operate together we kidded ourselves
this would be the setup for what we
called ellipse exercises every quarter
four times a year we did these complex
special operations exercises
to build the team into this effective
team and we would typically bring task
forces blue as a seal green as Delta red
as the Rangers we bring all this complex
entity together we're going to do a
complex operation to show how closely
our teamwork works but most of the
operations looked a lot like this there
would be three objectives the seals
would hit one objective Delta would hit
one objective and the Rangers would have
one objective geographically dispersed
so we didn't run into each other you
take those objectives down then you
return back to the base and then you'd
have this combined what we call a hot
washer actor action view see how it went
we didn't really do a complex operation
we really did three separate operations
in many cases the forces on those didn't
really work together they weren't really
in this training environment tightly
coupled so we didn't produce what we
thought we were producing we didn't
produce inside the organization that
shared consciousness between the larger
teams so where we got it right at the
low level automatically when we took it
up a level we got it wrong but didn't
think we have it wrong so how do you
scale this how do you get it up and make
it work at larger levels because this is
where it gets hard anybody can make a
basketball team work together almost
anybody
you start with one team small team you
got emotional and intellectual
connections that have to be built at the
emotional level you know everybody at
the intellectual level you all have
total awareness and that's pretty easy
to do when you start to go at a higher
level bigger suddenly you have to take a
team of team approach because there's
just things you can't do to make an
individual team cannot be too large so
the approach has to be somebody has to
know somebody else or someone else in
another organization so there have got
to be connections not between every
individual but between every
organization at some human level and you
have to have practical contextual
awareness not everybody can do
everything but you've got to have enough
linkage
so that it pulls you into a similar
relationship that the small team enjoys
think about the old system as you try to
build this intellectual synchronizations
you try to get everybody on the same
sheet of music inside our vertical silo
and our old elegant solution we
typically had things which made that
work you had environmental context
everybody shared they saw what was
happening in their part of the factory
their part of the business they got that
they had organizational context they
knew people they knew how it was
structured it was pretty comfortable and
technologically they were constrained it
was hard to reach out and talk to people
in the other part of the organization
because you had to go to another
building another state we didn't have
email phones quite as easily as we do
now so maintaining connections was
automatically constrained so it wasn't
assumed but all that's changed obviously
when you think of effective intellectual
synchronization we think of NASA and so
what do you think you think of the movie
Apollo 13 and think of the control room
and you think of failures not an option
everybody go in check check check check
check
the real miracle of NASA didn't occur in
the Apollo 13 control room it occurred
in the development of the Apollo program
which was amazing what they were doing
in less than a decade was creating
technology all of which was changing as
they did it pulling pieces of all this
technology together to create something
that was extraordinarily different from
anything that had been done and they
pulled this engineering effort together
at disparate locations in real time in
less than a decade it's probably one of
the best case studies of an organization
being able to share information remember
this is before they were empowered it
with as many information sharing tools
as we have now in Joint Special
Operations Command when I took over we
had a very small update every day for
leaders in the organization so we kind
of get in a huddle and past information
synchronize we started with about 50
people in it
by the time up I gave up command it was
more than seven
we did it every day 90 minutes long
every day essentially the whole command
so everybody shared information knew
where we were going what we're doing and
what updates and changes had occurred so
you need some kind of robust
communication form doesn't all look the
same but there's got to be a way where
everybody develops that shared
consciousness and you got to be
emotionally tied because people act on
emotion we started with frequent casual
exposure you know you run into people
think about it if you don't see somebody
in a long time it's hard to have
conversations but if you see them
constantly in your dorm in your office
wherever you start to talk
we were running operations that
dependent upon aircraft who did
surveillance did full motion video and
we had fighters shooters up our
operators who were going to go on the
targets as much as possible I brought
all of those to single base locations
because what I wanted is I wanted the
pilot who is going to fly that very
sensitive reconnaissance mission during
the attack when they came back and they
went to the mess hall I wanted them to
run into the operators who'd been on the
mission and I wanted them to feel shared
and if one of them screwed it up I
wanted them to see each other eyeball to
eyeball because it's a lot easier to
screw somebody that you don't have to
see the next day but we had to go even
deeper we had to also do embedded
exposure what we did was in fact the
seals in Delta didn't have diplomatic
relations when I took over it was sort
of like Iraq and Iran which was amazing
because they're very similar in culture
and background but maybe too similar so
I said okay we're gonna have an exchange
program you're going to take people from
the organization's exchange and put them
in the organization's of the other
assault teams and the first thing I was
told can't do it cannot be done because
we grow up together we have our culture
we've got to rely on the guide or right
and left and so it's unfair to put this
external person in there
and I understood that and I recognized I
said but that's alright we're going
do it anyway because it's hard to hate
somebody you know with a few exceptions
but some months after we started doing
this we had a firefight in Iraq and one
of our operators was shot and he lost
his leg and the investigation turned out
he'd been shot by friendly fire he'd
been shot by one of our own operators
and then we found out he'd not only been
shot by one of his own operators he'd
been shot by one of the exchange guys
from the outside and I said that's it
everybody's going to bring out every
antibody to this and they're going to
throw this on the table and they're
going to tell me see you're responsible
you got it wrong that's not what
happened
they said no that stuff happens he was
doing the right thing he's one of us
let's move on to include the guy who
lost his leg we had been just long
enough where they had gotten over that
and now it became an empowering thing
the guy who lost his leg interestingly
enough courageous guy 18 months later
was back in the fight on a prosthetic
leg still is so shared consciousness
really with our meaning of life ball
here is a combination of the
intellectual and emotional components of
this but back to speed it's one thing to
get it right as long as you get it right
fast enough as fast as you have to have
it this was a real problem for us
because if you think back to the
original hierarchical model we always
draw a triangle for this at the top of
that model what do you got you got
information going up where people think
that's where the thinkers are people
that have assigned parking spaces
and at the bottom they give commands
down you got people who are doing it
people are actually doing to work so you
got the people up here thinking and the
people down here doing and yet it can be
a problem there's a lot of history for
it if you think of army units
traditionally they're very much direct
armies would get in formation they would
march in formation the whole purpose was
to get everybody at the same place at
the same time so you could focus either
in combat or otherwise without losing
people and being disorganized the Navy
had a different approach inside a ship
there was tremendous discipline and
focus but once a ship was sent you
couldn't talk to it when Admiral Perry
went to open Japan they kind of patted
him on the head and say going over there
and do an incredibly important thing for
American foreign policy let us know how
it goes
they couldn't guide him so they didn't
try to they said go out and do what
makes sense
pretty interesting difference an
adaptive adapting to situation but
nowadays there's this danger there's
this seduction of situational awareness
you can get on the internet you can read
every paper you can talk to people you
can call anybody you want you can do it
real time by 2005 and late on to the
rest of my tour I could sit in my
command center and in the command center
there were about 8 or 12 of these
flat-panel screens and what they would
have is full motion video downlink from
predators and other air things they're
giving me real-time TV coverage of every
operation we're doing and I could sit
there and I could watch everything
that's happened I could watch what's
going on on the target I could watch the
raid force I could arrive I could watch
the the firefight and because we took
the radio signals and pumped him into
our internet I could listen to every
radio call I could listen down at the
lowest level I could just an operator
one talking operator two and guess what
if I wanted to I could push a button I
could talk to him but I never did
because I realized that that was the
seduction of situation awareness I
didn't really know what was going on I
was watching it on TV but I wasn't down
or I wasn't here in the crack of bullets
I wasn't cold I wasn't scared I didn't
have a feel for what was actually
happening but the danger is because we
get all this data now we watch what's
happening
to here square in real-time we say what
we think we know what's happening in
Egypt of course we don't we may have
more data but it's even more complex
than that and so one of the dangers is
not falling prey to this so which we
really had to do to make this work fast
enough with to change the thinker's into
doers the doers into thinkers that
everybody became both and it changed not
just how we operated and change the
culture of who we were and how we
thought of what we did we inverted the
model we decoupled the relationship
between information and control I fi of
the information I have control because
now we could get the information to
everybody and more people control what
they did which allowed us to do what we
call empowered execution we say
decentralized operations you know if you
take decentralized operations too
simplistically you're just pushing your
problem down to other people and say do
it if you don't also give them the
authorities and the information they're
operating blind and it's unfair and
ineffective but if you empower them with
those things suddenly empowered
execution lets people operate at the
right level decisions be made at the
right level effectively and they also
feel differently about it they say how
much should you D centralized
decentralized until you're uncomfortable
and then decentralized one more what did
it do for us how does it play back to me
in the summer of 2008 August 2008 my
force in Iraq did 18 raids that's about
one every other night now I thought we
were at a breakneck pace I thought we
were just pedal-to-the-metal how could
you do more operations than one every
other night because they were planned
and they were rehearsed and they were
reported up to me and then I proved them
and then they do them just couldn't do
it but we were still losing and not only
we were losing we were starting to lose
even more so we changed how we operated
and two years later we were in the fight
the whole time there two years later
same month same force same everything
else we did 300 raids that month 10
night we kept that pace up for two and a
half years you couldn't have done that
in a traditional hierarchical model so
when you think about inverting the model
really the two things that became
critical first were shared consciousness
we've talked about letting people have a
clear shared understanding and then the
idea that you're going to empower
execution and the to support each other
they're mutually reinforcing and that's
what we now call cross lead for those of
you who are in love with the elegant
model this is just to make you feel good
because your worship at the mantra of
efficiency and you have your profits we
all had our profits and they weren't
wrong we got a century of extraordinary
value out of being efficiency minded but
we're not playing that sport anymore the
game has changed the battlefield the
environment whatever you want to call it
has changed and now I believe the secret
is adaptability and it's being able to
increase our adaptability constantly not
just our personal adaptability but at
every level thank you and I'll be happy
to answer any questions
the question was what's a single most
unexpected thing that I learned it was
probably wrapped up into this I expected
that if we got better and better at what
we did if we honed our skills shoot
straighter fly faster do all of those
things that if we got good that our
technological and quality mismatch would
allow us to win that was true at the
tactical level we won every firefight we
had night vision goggles we had Global
Positioning System we had incredible
people you know with tremendous skills
and courage so we won every firefight
the problem is that doesn't equate to
winning the war and for about two years
I pressed this organization to get
better at what we do better what we do
better what we do and we're winning all
the firefights and I'm telling myself
therefore we'll just do this long enough
we'll win the war that wasn't right it
was like a thousand people taking an
accent and and chopping on a tree but
they're all hit in different spots a lot
of barks flying and what an opportune
time it wasn't until we figured out to
change that model and we had to get more
focused into the big outcome that that
it worked and it ultimately did we broke
out Qaeda in Iraq now they're coming
back but it's for reasons of internal to
Iraq sir general McChrystal good
afternoon my name is Phil misere I'm an
MBA one and a former Navy pilot you
spoke a little bit about how the drones
had kind of affected your situational
awareness and I'd like to ask you
another question about how drones can
perhaps affect the calculus when
decision makers are making decisions
from a tactical level as a commander it
seems like the use of drones makes a lot
of sense when you're going after a
target if I've got to choose between a
manned aircraft and a drone I'm going to
pick a drone every day because we don't
put a service member at risk but from a
strategic perspective when our civilian
decision makers are making decisions to
use force or not to use force do you
think that the use of
drones or the capability of drones
alters the calculus and makes it easier
yeah that's a great question let me let
me frame it a little bit first I think
drones are here to stay
we're going to use them we need to use
them and they're important part of what
we do I'm actually going to use them
even more so I think that's important
but they are different they're different
because they are perceived differently
now if you think about it there are
several factors is the first is go back
to 1988 anybody remember what happened
in 1988 how many of you weren't born in
1988 that's very sad
President Clinton ordered Tomahawk
missile strikes into Afghanistan and to
Sudan in response to pretty clear
activities in the part of the Salman bin
Laden now if those timeout missiles
didn't kill ubl but they killed various
people created damage if you Dasia
average American the next morning if we
were at war what would we have said no
we're not at war we fired some Tomahawk
missiles if you were near the impact
point of a Tomahawk missile and you
asked the next morning if they were at
war with America what do you think
they'd say the answer is probably
different so if it lowers the threshold
on the use of military force it's
dangerous and what I mean if it can be
too casual it can seem too easy too
inexpensive too risk-free and it
increases your likelihood of doing it
then I would say everyone who orders one
ought to go stand next to where one has
gone off and where you see body parts
and and things like that it's very
different so I'm not saying we don't use
I'm saying you got to make sure you
understand what you're doing the other
part of it is perceptions we've got
problems with some Mexican drug lords in
the US and whatnot the Mexicans are
after them but what if Mexico flew
across the border with drones and did a
missile strike in Texas how would we
respond probably not well and it's the
perception of we can step back and hurl
fun
bolts like Thor without any risk to
ourselves that's viewed as arrogance now
whether that's right or wrong
perceptions matter in the world that's
why people go to war because they
perceive something so I think we've got
to be very very thoughtful about how
everything we do is actually perceived
by others cannot throw out the capacity
entirely but be really thoughtful about
it